Okay, well, we heard from a viewer
who really wanted your help in the first date department.
So let's take a look at this clip.
Hi, Drew.
My name's Rachael.
I live in Lynnwood, Washington, and I'm 46 years old.
I have a son that's 17,
and this fall, he'll be heading off to college.
I've been divorced for about 10 years,
and I am very interested in prioritizing dating.
I have recently lost over 120 pounds
and I am very excited to meet new people.
My hope is that Damona can help me with advice
on how to take on my next first date.
First dates are first impressions and it always counts.
I could really use some advice.
Could you help me?
She's doing the right thing.
Absolutely.
(audience applauds)
Please welcome, someone I totally relate to, Rachael.
Hi, Rachael.
Hi.
(audience applauds)
Okay, Rachael, what scares you the most
about a first date?
Well, I would say what worries me most
or possibly scares me
is if a man hasn't been completely honest on his profile
and of course the guy that's too aggressive.
Damona, what are your general tips
for those particular anxieties or first dates in general?
Well, I do wanna acknowledge
those things are definite red flags,
so you gotta look out for those.
Those things that make you feel uncomfortable,
that's always your first thing to guide you
through the date.
I want you to also prepare for the dates a little bit,
and to remember how important body language is.
So don't be afraid, you got this new body,
you lost 120 pounds.
That's amazing, amazing.
Thank you.
(audience cheers)
You look so beautiful.
Thank you.
Yeah.
So live in your body, use it, use your body language.
And then you've gotta prepare for the date.
So I want you, I'm gonna give you a little homework,
I want you to create a curiosity list
the next time that you have a date,
things that you're just curious to know about them.
And also prepare for the questions you will inevitably get,
which are, what do you like to do for fun?
What are you looking for?
Why are you divorced?
Which you are not obligated to answer.
So have a coy, fun comment at the ready
when you get that question, 'cause you inevitably will.
And then, what do you think the ideal length
of a first date is?
Well, actually, that is one of my questions,
how long should a first date last?
About an hour.
And I want you to think of it like this.
You want the energy to feel like
it is ending on a high point, it's ending in the middle.
So most people will remember the beginning of a date
and the end of a date.
But if the end of the date is like, we went for three hours,
we had dinner, we ran out of things to talk about,
that's what you'll remember, and that's what he'll remember.
So even if you're having a great time,
I know it's very hard,
we have to just hold back a little bit,
and end the date feeling like it's in the middle,
and you'll probably get an invitation for the next one.
(audience applauds)
Rachael, I think you have another question.
Last question for Damona, I'd love for you to ask.
Oh yes, I do.
Now, if there is no chemistry
and the guy is quite a gentleman,
should I go on a second date?
Oh yeah, why not?
Why not?
I mean, on a first date,
most people are not really themselves anyway.
If you're still curious by the end of the first date
to know more about him, go on the second date.
If you're still curious by the end of the second date,
go on a third.
I have a three date rule.
If by the end of the third date,
you're not feeling anything, then you can let it go,
but you've given it your best shot.
To remember this, I'll give you a little phrase.
Drew loves my little zingers.
Sparks in three or let it be. (laughs)
I like that.
That'll keep you motivated.
Sparks in three or let it be.
(Damona laughs)
Rachael, how does this feel?
Great, I really appreciate your advice very much.
It's my pleasure, I'm here to help.
(upbeat bright music)